date you the israeli cabinet has
approved
a ceasefire to begin at 2 a.m local time
on friday morning in about three and a
half hours time and we're just getting
word from hamas
uh mark stone is with me what are they
saying uh they are saying
that mutual and simultaneous truths with
israel will begin
at 2 a.m on friday so after 11 days
of of conflict of bloodshed on both
sides but
heavily on the palestinian side uh they
will stop fighting
at 2 a.m on friday uh well
in what is it three and a half hours
time i wonder though whether we would
expect over the next
in that time in the next three hours
that they there will still be
rockets fired from gaza and retaliatory
strikes what we've seen in the past is
in those last hours
pointless as it may seem the fighting
continues and
and then it stops in terms of what's
been achieved well
politically benjamin netanyahu is now
more powerful than he was 12 days ago
when he was fighting for his political
life militarily the israelis have
managed to
degrade hamas's capability massively
although
it's worth stressing they were surprised
by how
capable hamas was at being able to
strike places like tel aviv over the
past 11 days for hamas
they can claim that they put themselves
at the center of the quest for
palestinian
equality palestinian statehood
politically hamas has
played a clever game by alienating the
palestinian authority
fatah in the west bank they've done very
well there politically calculated on
their behalf
but where does it leave the people well
i mean gaza is a mess again
and in terms of that elusive two-state
solution the core
problems here in israel palestine well
nothing's changed there at all but i
fuel food you know much needed medicine
can now we hope
get in yeah although on that point i
i've just been speaking to the to the un
and they do they say that the the gaza
power plan as it's known the fuel
is set to run out on friday um and
at the moment the israelis are saying
fuel won't be allowed back in because
they're worried that hamas will use it
for rockets whether or not this hamas
statement in the last few minutes
changes that we'll we'll see but
certainly the key now is getting aid in
very fast
right and in three and a half hours time
it's over yeah well
for now but we've been here many times
before yeah cyclical we have but we can
say i think
uh a little bit of good news at the end
of what has been a pretty bleak
what is it now 11 days 11 days yeah